another thing Dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation Dr bright you  are not a pirate okay first of all who  told Dr bright about Talk Like a Pirate  Day he doesn't need more reasons to  dress up in a costume and bother  everyone well I guess that's one cat we  can't put back in the bag so new rule  whether it's Talk Like a Pirate Day or  not Dr bright is not allowed to Keel  haul anyone or force them to quote walk  the plank where did he even get a plank  even if he's wearing an eye patch and  even if he says are Mighty a lot and by  the way Dr bright yo ho ho and a bottle  of rum is not appropriate for the  workplace leave the bottle at home and  this is also why the rum is always gone